Tasha:你现在走吗
Tasha: Are you leaving now?
Tasha:明天没有票
Tasha: No tickets for tomorrow.
Tasha:没有
Tasha: None.
Jake:明天有票
Jake: There are tickets for tomorrow.
Tasha:明天下午要汇报呢
Tasha: I have a report to present tomorrow afternoon.
Tasha:我要回学校
Tasha: I need to go back to school.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:好吧 下了
Tasha: Okay, getting off.
Tasha:谁敲门了吗
Tasha: Did someone knock on the door?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:手机给我把我要点外卖
Tasha: Give me the phone, I want to order takeout.
Jake:唉 还不能点 哎你先
Jake: Hey, you can't order yet. Hey, you first...
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure: 还下吗
Shure: Are you getting off?
Tasha:哇有点冷
Tasha: Wow, it's a bit cold.
Lucia: 对因为下雨了
Lucia: Yeah, because it's raining.
Tasha:突然间感觉有点冷
Tasha: Suddenly feeling a bit cold.
Lucia:一会穿点衣服穿个小外套什么的
Lucia: Put on some clothes, like a little jacket or something.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia:离你远点了我都
Lucia: I'm moving a bit away from you.
Jake:请带眼镜
Jake: Please wear glasses.
Jake:唉 在桌子上
Jake: Hey, it's on the table.
Lucia:唉谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thanks.
Jake:离你最近的桌子上
Jake: It's on the table closest to you.
Tasha:变天了你不冷吗
Tasha: The weather's changing, aren't you cold?
Jake:我还不冷
Jake: I'm not cold yet.
Tasha:下雨了
Tasha: It's raining.
Jake:你 那就给你一件厚衣裳
Jake: Then I'll get you a thick coat.
Tasha:神经
Tasha: Crazy.
Tasha:眼镜在哪里
Tasha: Where are the glasses?
Tasha:我不穿是因为
Tasha: I'm not wearing them because...
Lucia:我需要一块眼镜布
Lucia: I need a glasses cloth.
Jake:有嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha:唉我刚刚擦了
Tasha: Hey, I just wiped them.
Lucia:楼上东西太多我今天刚用完
Lucia: There's too much stuff upstairs, I just used one today.
Lucia:买了一瓶然后忘记在哪里了
Lucia: I bought a bottle and then forgot where I put it.
Lucia:thank you
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:给你
Jake: Here you go.
Lucia:thank you
Lucia: Thank you.
Tasha:点外卖了又
Tasha: Ordering takeout again?
Jake:又要吃外卖
Jake: Ordering takeout again.
Lucia:吃什么呀
Lucia: What should we eat?
Tasha:不能打车去吗
Tasha: Can't we just take a cab?
Jake:去哪里
Jake: Where to?
Tasha:不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Jake:那就打车去哪里吧
Jake: Then let's just take a cab somewhere.
Lucia:吃饭了
Lucia: Time to eat.
Lucia:薇薇想吃什么
Lucia: Tasha, what do you want to eat?
Tasha:啥也不想吃
Tasha: I don't feel like eating anything.
Tasha:能不能吃点感觉又不腻又很好吃
Tasha: Can we have something that's both tasty and not too greasy?
Tasha:又不长泡又
Tasha: And also doesn't cause any breakouts...
Lucia:听说过不可能几个字吗
Lucia: Have you heard of the word "impossible"?
Lucia:就三个里面可能塞两个
Lucia: You might get two out of three.
Tasha:有什么想吃的吗
Tasha: Do you have any cravings?
Lucia:我都还好
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Lucia:薇薇做蛋糕很好吃就是现在食欲低
Lucia: Tasha's cakes are delicious, but I'm not really hungry now.
Tasha:我有点受不了啦
Lucia:哎哎我手呢 有一点甜
Lucia: Oh, my hand is a bit sticky.
Lucia:不过是蛋糕吧甜点正常
Lucia: But it's cake, so some mess is normal.
Tasha:吃完这块蛋糕再吃不下的东西
Tasha: After I finish this cake, I can't eat anything else.
Tasha:今天晚上不吃了
Tasha: No more food tonight.
我们俩一天100块钱
Together we spend 100 yuan a day.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:平常晚上能吃80啊
Jake: Normally, we can eat 80 at night.
Jake:平常晚上能吃80
Tasha:早上也没吃呀
Tasha: But we didn't eat breakfast.
Lucia:他开始录了吗
Lucia: Did he start recording?
Lucia:哦没事
Lucia: Oh, never mind.
Tasha:怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Lucia:不是不是
Lucia: Nothing, nothing.
Lucia:没啥我就是
Lucia: It's just that...
Lucia:就是刚才你说的时候我突然想起来
Lucia: When you mentioned it, I just remembered...
Lucia:就是有一个
Lucia: There's this...
Lucia:就是这个不能算经济学理论
Lucia: This can't really be considered an economic theory.
Tasha:就是能被剪进去的吗
Tasha: Can it be edited in?
Lucia:我不确定能不能贯通
Lucia: I'm not sure if it connects.
Tasha:哦我开着呢
Tasha: Oh, I'm recording.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia:哦应该没事
Lucia: Oh, it should be fine.
因为它不是一个具体的实例
Because it's not a specific example.
Lucia:就是一般来说
Lucia: Generally speaking
Lucia:就是当你要执行什么预算的时候
Lucia: When you're working on a budget
Lucia:最好是顶格而花
Lucia: It's best to spend it all
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right
Lucia:因为而且就是至少从至少从财政学上
Lucia: Because, at least from a financial perspective
Lucia:来说因为第二年的预算
Lucia: The next year's budget is based on
Lucia:基本上是下一年的情况来批
Lucia: The situation of the previous year
Lucia:就是就是
Lucia: It's like
Lucia:它不是一个个例
Lucia: It's not an isolated case
Lucia:就是甚至全世界基本都是这样的
Lucia: It's pretty much the same worldwide
Lucia:所以如果你前一年花不完的话
Lucia: So if you don't spend it all one year
Lucia:第二年下个月就会变少
Lucia: The next year's budget will be less
Lucia:所以需要定格化
Lucia: So you need to spend it all
Lucia:所以我们吃东西要定格吃
Lucia: That's why we need to eat up everything
Tasha:所以这并不在于
Tasha: So it doesn't matter
Lucia:就是我们平常晚上都能吃80
Lucia: We usually eat up to 80
Lucia:而是我回收他收了80
Lucia: But I'm recycling 80
Jake:就是80
Jake: It's 80
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes
Lucia:我来提供一下理论支持
Lucia: Let me provide some theoretical support
Tasha:谢谢
Tasha: Thanks
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:走我们去吃80
Jake: Let's go eat 80
Lucia:你怎么不让我们去吃白食呢
Lucia: Why don't we just go eat for free
Jake:哈哈哈吃白食
Jake: Hahaha eat for free
Lucia:这些闲鱼梗太多了
Lucia: Too many idle jokes
Tasha:不知道感觉这个别墅里面空荡荡的
Tasha: I don't know, this villa feels so empty
Tasha:知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Tasha:就是只有几个人在始终的来回窜动
Tasha: Only a few people moving around all the time
Lucia:哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right
Lucia:平常就平常
Lucia: Usually, usually
Lucia:前几天中午午休的时候也是这样子的
Lucia: It's like this during noon breaks too
Lucia:然后我经常就会想
Lucia: And I often think
Lucia:是如果说我们在这个房间
Lucia: If we're in this room
Lucia:就偶然有一两个人来回的时候
Lucia: And there's just one or two people moving around
Lucia:就这个图像一定会显得非常奇怪
Lucia: The scene would look really weird
就有一种
Lucia: It's like
Lucia:那种怎么形容展厅影像的那种感觉
Lucia: How do I describe it, like an exhibit video
Lucia:就那种我每次去参观博物馆时候
Lucia: Every time I visit a museum
Lucia:都对一些现代展厅影像
Lucia: It's like those modern exhibit videos
Lucia:不知所云的那种感觉
Lucia: That feeling when it doesn't make any sense.
Lucia:都可以
Lucia: Anything's fine.
Tasha:开什么玩笑
Tasha: Are you kidding me?
Tasha:好我选择退出Wifi圈哈哈
Tasha: Alright, I choose to leave the Wifi circle, haha.
Lucia:决赛圈第一位选手已经退出了
Lucia: The first contestant in the final round has left.
Tasha:我退出了
Tasha: I left.
Lucia:我觉得我们最怎么说呢
Lucia: I think we, how do I say this...
Lucia:花的时间最久
Lucia: We spent the most time.
Lucia:而且就是花样最多的人就是吃哈哈
Lucia: And we had the most variety in what we ate, haha.
Jake:这才是生活
Jake: This is life.
Lucia:我感觉就就就够了
Lucia: I feel like it's enough.
这不是普通人的生活哈哈
This isn't an ordinary person's life, haha.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:摆烂了吗这是
Tasha: Are we just giving up?
Jake:那有猫
Jake: There's a cat.
Lucia:猫在院子里
Lucia: The cat's in the yard.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:今天大扫除一般
Tasha: Today is like a big clean-up.
Tasha:不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha:我老爱丢皮筋带了十根
Tasha: I always lose my hair ties. I brought ten.
Tasha:昨天的梳头发一根都没有
Tasha: Yesterday when I combed my hair, none left.
Lucia:我也爱丢皮筋
Lucia: I lose hair ties too.
Lucia:但是那种上面带花的
Lucia: But the ones with flowers on them.
Tasha:我丢的就会少一些
Tasha: I lose those less often.
Katrina: 你要把裤子收回来
Katrina: You need to take your pants back.
哦OK OK谢谢
Oh, OK OK, thanks.
Shure: 来吃瓜
Shure: Come eat melon.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Shure: 吃瓜
Shure: Eat melon.
Tasha:哇这个瓜看上去好不错耶
Tasha: Wow, this melon looks so good.
Jake:我们要不出去吃
Jake: Why don't we go out to eat?
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina: 你看你要走了
Katrina: Look, you're leaving.
Katrina: 老天都下雨了
Katrina: It's even raining now.
Katrina: 哎小猫咪又来了
Katrina: Hey, the little cat's back.
Katrina: 他刚看着我跑了
Katrina: He ran when he saw me.
Katrina: 你看它又跑
Katrina: Look, he's running again.
Jake:给他他吃瓜
Jake: Give him the melon to eat.
Jake:它可以吃瓜对吧
Jake: It can eat melon, right?
Jake:给他点瓜皮
Jake: Give it some melon rind.
Katrina: 又走了
Katrina: It's gone again.
Shure: 家人们不下了
Shure: Family, we're not going down.
Jake:不下了吗
Jake: Not going down?
Shure: 不下了哎
Shure: Not going down.
Jake:那就去挂彩票了
Jake: Then let's go scratch lottery tickets.
Shure: 看错了对不起
Shure: I read it wrong, sorry.
不下了那就去刮彩票
Not going down, then let's go scratch lottery tickets.
Lucia:把我看成你了是吧
Lucia: Did you mistake me for someone else?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 我第一眼差点顺口叫个宝哈哈
Shure: At first glance, I almost called you "babe" by accident, haha.
Lucia:那还是别
Lucia: Better not.
Shure: 不下了吧
Shure: Not going down, right?
Jake:有事是吧
Jake: Got something to do, right?
Jake:为什么不带眼镜
Jake: Why aren't you wearing glasses?
Tasha:你也没开啊
Tasha: You didn't start either.
Tasha:为什么你老好意思说别人
Tasha: Why do you always criticize others?
Lucia:啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:不要一天老盯着别人
Lucia: Don't keep staring at others all day.
Lucia:先把自己的事情干好
Lucia: Take care of your own stuff first.
Jake:是反对反对
Jake: Yes, I oppose, I oppose.
Lucia:小学老师的那种感觉
Lucia: Feels like an elementary school teacher.
Lucia:没有小充电宝了吗
Lucia: No more small power banks?
Jake:有
Jake: There are.
Jake:有一些没电了估计
Jake: Some might be out of power though.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:一会儿刮彩票吗
Jake: Are we scratching lottery tickets later?
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia:不是下雨了吗
Lucia: Isn't it raining?
Jake:修硕说停
Jake: Shure said it stopped.
Katrina: 今天晚上有啥安排吗
Katrina: Any plans for tonight?
Katrina: 你们下午干了什么
Katrina: What did you do this afternoon?
Jake:应该是拆屋子
Jake: Probably demolishing the house.
Katrina: 拆今天晚上拆屋子
Katrina: Demolish the house tonight?
Jake:对就是给你打包嘛
Jake: Yeah, just packing it up for you.
Jake:要把屋子给恢复原样
Jake: We need to restore the house to its original state.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 还有半个瓜在楼上
Shure: There's half a melon upstairs.
Shure: 然后你们想吃的话记得切着吃
Shure: If you guys want to eat it, remember to slice it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then
Shure: 是遗嘱是吧
Shure: It's the will, right?
Shure: 对遗嘱了
Shure: Yes, the will.
Shure: 最后教再交代两句
Shure: Finally, just a few last words.
Katrina: 那这些东西怎么办呀
Katrina: What about these things?
Shure: 然后线 归还
Shure: Then return the line.
Tasha:所以你们走
Tasha: So you're leaving?
Tasha:你们回去
Tasha: Are you going back?
Tasha:回去了吗
Shure: 对我们准备回去了直接
Shure: Yes, we're going straight back.
Jake:就刷一刷
Jake: Just clean up a bit.
Jake:比如说那个盘子吗
Jake: Like that plate?
Katrina: 我说这些没有用完的
Katrina: I mean those that haven't been used up.
Shure: 我的手机
Shure: My phone.
Jake:这些放哪呢
Jake: Where to put these?
Katrina: 你带回去吗
Katrina: Will you take it back?
Shure: 把这个都停掉
Shure: Stop all of this.
Jake:嗯你想带走就带走
Jake: Hmm, take it if you want.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake:带不走就放那吧
Jake: If not, just leave it there.
Katrina: 感觉扔掉好浪费啊
Katrina: Feels like a waste to throw it away.
Jake:是的是呀
Jake: Yes, it is.
Tasha:扔掉好浪费啊
Tasha: It's a waste to throw it away.
Tasha:带回去我在学校也没法做呀
Tasha: If I take it back, I can't use it at school.
Jake:好说
Jake: Fair enough.
Jake:卖掉
Jake: Sell it.
Tasha:卖掉
Tasha: Sell it.
Tasha:你卖分我一半就行
Tasha: You sell it and give me half.
Jake:为什么 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Why? Hahaha
Tasha:可是他要两他两包起卖
Tasha: But he wants to sell two packs at a time.
Tasha:两包好像才5块钱
Tasha: Two packs are only 5 yuan.
Katrina: 主要是卖给谁啊
Katrina: Who would buy it anyway?
Lucia:就是没拆的
Lucia: The unopened ones.
Lucia:我们可以比如说大家装一下
Lucia: We can, for example, pack them up together.
Lucia:或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia:拆了的就不太好带或者
Lucia: The opened ones are hard to take.
Tasha:玉米淀粉
Tasha: Cornstarch.
Tasha:做汤可能会用到
Tasha: Might use it to make soup.
Tasha:寄给我妈吧
Tasha: I'll send it to my mom.
Katrina: 哦他这能寄快递
Katrina: Oh, he can send a courier.
Katrina: 能上门取件吗
Katrina: Can they pick it up from home?
Jake:对这个可以
Jake: Yes, they can.
Jake:哦 那今天晚上让他上门取
Jake: Oh, then let's have them pick it up tonight.
Katrina: 柯欣呢
Katrina: Where's Kexin?
Tasha:噜噜噜在房间里
Tasha: Lulu is in the room.
Tasha:他们居然啊
Tasha: Can you believe it?
Katrina: 他们怎么了
Katrina: What happened to them?
Tasha:睡觉了
Tasha: They're asleep.
Katrina: 哦原来退伍啊
Katrina: Oh, they're retired.
Katrina: 你去把那个放下
Katrina: You go put that down.
Katrina: 把骏马放下
Katrina: Put the horse down.
Katrina: 哈哈哈 噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Hahaha, dun dun dun dun.
Jake:我们应该列队 然后
Jake: We should line up, and then...
Lucia:拎个枪什么的吗
Lucia: Carry a gun or something?
Jake:枪毙是吧
Jake: Executed, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Jake:我们第一位叛徒哈哈
Jake: Our first traitor, haha.
Katrina: 明早啥时候退房啊
Katrina: What time are we checking out tomorrow morning?
Lucia:12点
Lucia: 12 o'clock.
Katrina: 我们早上
Katrina: In the morning...
Katrina: 自己想什么时候走就什么时候走吗
Katrina: Can we leave whenever we want?
Katrina: 还是
Katrina: Or...
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:12点退房吗
Jake: Check out at 12?
Jake:就是12点之前
Jake: Just before 12.
Shure: 他们那个刘帅和XBZ是开车来的吗
Shure: Did Choiszt and XBZ drive here?
Jake:刘帅也来
Jake: Choiszt is coming too.
Shure: 刘帅来吗
Shure: Is Choiszt coming?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia:那一会是要过来吗
Lucia: Are they coming over later?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:XBZ要来
Jake: XBZ is coming.
Shure: 谢彬竹要来
Shure: Xie Binzhu is coming?
让他明天帮我把把行礼带回去
Shure: Ask him to help bring my luggage back tomorrow.
Jake:他太惨了
Jake: He's too pitiful.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia:他不是还发烧呢吗
Lucia: Isn't he still having a fever?
Shure: 他没死就行
Shure: As long as he's not dead, it's fine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈 这个话记住了
Tasha: Hahaha, remember these words.
Lucia:救命
Lucia: Help!
Katrina: 兄弟情
Katrina: Brotherhood.
Jake:别以为你自己不戴眼镜就
Jake: Don't think that just because you don't wear glasses...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:好你思念啥
Jake: Okay, what are you missing?
Lucia: 对啊 你北京本地
Lucia: Yeah, you're a local in Beijing.
Katrina: 顺点东西走吧
Katrina: Just take something with you.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 是不是充电宝哈哈哈
Shure: Is it a power bank? Hahaha
Jake:充充电宝
Jake: Charge the power bank.
Jake:XBZ给你点
Jake: XBZ will give you some.
Katrina: 可以顺充电宝吧
Katrina: Can we take the power bank?
Katrina: 我正好缺一个
Katrina: I happen to need one.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me too.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia:我们明天走出去
Lucia: We'll leave tomorrow.
Lucia:把自己用的这个充电宝给他顺走
Lucia: Take the power bank we've been using.
Shure: 还有一个我
Shure: And one for me too.
Katrina: 你要不要带点鸡蛋回去
Katrina: Do you want to take some eggs back?
Tasha:是这个吗
Tasha: Is it this one?
Tasha:这有个黑的
Tasha: There's a black one here.
Tasha:哦 算了那就不是
Tasha: Oh, never mind, it's not that one.
Shure: 有一个大的
Shure: There's a big one.
Katrina: 你端一盒鸡蛋回去吧
Katrina: Take a box of eggs back.
Lucia:对刚好你在北京这个不容易散
Lucia: Yeah, it's not easy to get them in Beijing.
Katrina: 补点营养
Katrina: Get some nutrition.
Katrina: 还有你的咸鸭蛋
Katrina: And your salted duck eggs.
Tasha:带
Tasha: Take them.
Shure: 哦 还有咸鸭蛋
Shure: Oh, salted duck eggs too.
Shure: 那箱子不好使
Shure: That box isn't good.
Katrina: 还有酒
Katrina: And wine.
Shure: 我ipad 还没放时去
Shure: I haven't put my iPad away yet.
Shure: 酒我带了一瓶
Shure: I brought a bottle of wine.
Katrina: 好家伙
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha: 我天哪
Tasha: Oh my god.
Shure: 咖啡给我装好
Shure: Pack my coffee well.
Katrina: 瓜分
Katrina: Divvy it up.
Shure: 哦对杨老板还有报销账单我没领
Shure: Oh right, Jake, I haven't gotten the reimbursement bill yet.
Jake:哎哈哈
Jake: Oh, hahaha.
Jake:哎 行行行
Jake: Hey, alright, alright.
Tasha:杨老板什么时候结
Tasha: Jake, when will you...
Tasha:我的也没报呢
Tasha: I haven't reported mine yet.
Jake:好好好给你
Jake: Okay, okay, I'll do it for you.
Lucia:加一
Lucia: Add me too.
Shure: 我们临走前把钱款两清
Shure: Let's settle all the money before we leave.
Katrina:  哈哈今今晚算账是吧
Katrina: Haha, are we settling accounts tonight?
Shure: 不当面结清
Shure: Let's not do it face-to-face.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你买了啥呀
Katrina: What did you buy?
Katrina: 他屋子好像也没买啥
Katrina: It doesn't seem like he bought anything.
Shure: 我屋子里没买啥
Shure: I didn't buy anything for my room.
Shure: 我吃饭点了
Shure: I ordered food.
Katrina: 你帮我点
Katrina: You ordered for me.
Katrina: 点外卖了是吗
Katrina: Did you order takeout?
Shure: 来帮我摁个计算器家人们
Shure: Help me press the calculator, everyone.
Tasha:你等会帮我也摁一下
Tasha: Wait and help me press it too.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Sure.
Tasha:算了你报吧
Tasha: Never mind, you report it.
Tasha:我来帮你加
Tasha: I'll help you add.
Shure: 首先139块8
Shure: First, 139.8.
Tasha:139.8
Tasha: 139.8.
Shure的女友:点8也要算进来
Shure: Even the 0.8 should be counted.
Shure: 去加94
Shure: Then add 94.
Katrina: 没有 四舍五四舍算客气了
Katrina: No, rounding off would be polite.
Jake:99哈哈
Jake: 99, haha.
Tasha:94
Tasha: 94.
Tasha:加
Tasha: Add.
Shure: 22块5毛7
Shure: 22.57.
Tasha:22.5毛7
Tasha: 22.57.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:那个7
Lucia: That 7.
Shure: 加40.8
Shure: Add 40.8.
Tasha:40.8
Tasha: 40.8.
Jake:写精确
Jake: Write it precisely.
Shure: 加96
Shure: Add 96.
Tasha:96
Tasha: 96.
Shure: 加49块5毛2
Shure: Add 49.52.
Tasha:49.5毛2
Tasha: 49.52.
Shure: 啊没有了
Shure: Ah, that's it.
Tasha:442.69
Tasha: 442.69
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright, got it.
Shure: 然后还有等一下
Shure: And then, wait a sec.
Jake:还有摸个0吧
Jake: Let's just round it to zero.
Jake:40 哈哈哈
Jake: 40, hahaha.
Jake:摸个0 40 哈哈哈
Jake: Round it to zero, 40, hahaha.
Tasha:你怎么不说0.69嘞
Tasha: Why not just say 0.69?
Tasha:摸个头吧
Tasha: Let's just round it off.
Shure: 看看这就是资本主义的压榨
Shure: See, this is the exploitation of capitalism.
Shure: 家人们我们要
Shure: Folks, we need to...
Tasha:警惕
Tasha: Be alert.
Shure: 警惕
Shure: Be alert.
Tasha:我都不敢把我的账单发给他看了
Tasha: I'm too scared to show him my bill.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me too.
Tasha:我这有2,000多的账要报
Tasha: I have over 2,000 to report.
Shure: 啊34块9毛8
Shure: Ah, 34.98
Tasha:34.9毛8
Tasha: 34.98
Shure: 还有一个咖啡豆钱
Shure: Plus the cost of coffee beans.
Tasha:咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Shure: 咖啡豆是
Shure: The coffee beans are...
Lucia:我觉得我们天天在这演群口相声
Lucia: I feel like we’re performing a group comedy sketch every day.
Shure: 148
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha:148的咖啡豆
Tasha: 148 coffee beans
Jake:这么整呢
Jake: How do we handle this?
Jake:假的吧
Jake: Is it fake?
Shure: 嗯是真的
Shure: Nope, it's real.
Jake:哈哈哈嗯
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Shure: 它两包起卖主要是
Shure: They sell it in packs of two mainly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Got it.
Jake:总共这么多钱
Jake: That's the total amount.
Jake:对 好 你是谁
Jake: Right, good. Who are you?
Shure: 我是哈哈哈
Shure: It's me, hahaha.
Shure: 没事咱咱扫码就行
Shure: No worries, we'll just scan the code.
Tasha:哈哈哈哦
Tasha: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 二维码收款ok
Shure: QR code payment is ok.
Tasha:来帮我加一下
Tasha: Come and help me add this.
Jake:等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait.
Jake:多少钱 625点
Jake: How much? 625 points.
Shure: 哎 摸个零吧
Shure: Hey, round it to zero.
Shure: 625就行了
Shure: 625 is fine.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 大方吗杨老板
Shure: Are you being generous, Jake?
Jake:哎是挺好
Jake: Yes, it's pretty good.
Shure: 给你省了1/100新币 哈哈哈
Shure: Saved you 1/100 of a new currency, haha.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
Tasha:你怎么不帮我啊
Tasha: Why aren't you helping me?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Oh my God.
Jake:来互摁是吧
Jake: Let's press it together, right?
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
Jake:来 摁一下
Jake: Come on, press it.
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven 30.
Lucia:你看这就是单次博弈的坏处
Lucia: See, this is the downside of single-round games.
Lucia:你们俩要是经常互相摁的话
Lucia: If you guys press it for each other often,
Lucia:双方就会
Lucia: Both sides will...
Jake:啊就有默契是吧
Jake: Ah, you'll have a mutual understanding, right?
Lucia:不是开始胡说八道了
Lucia: No, you start talking nonsense.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha:30烤箱加24跑腿
Tasha: 30 for the oven, plus 24 for the delivery.
Shure: 24
Shure: 24.
Tasha:装修房间493
Tasha: Renovating the room is 493.
Shure: 496
Shure: 496.
Tasha:加25的地毯
Tasha: Plus 25 for the carpet.
Shure: 25地毯钱
Shure: 25 for the carpet.
Tasha:加达美乐点餐220
Tasha: Plus 220 for Domino's order.
Shure: 220加
Shure: 220 plus.
Tasha:跑腿16
Tasha: Delivery 16.
Shure: 16加
Shure: 16 plus.
薇:盒马702
Tasha: Hema 702.
Shure: 哈哈 哦
Shure: Haha, oh.
Jake:我草哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my God, haha.
Shure: 噢 盒马
Shure: Oh, Hema.
Shure: 都让人家付的
Shure: They paid for everything.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha:厨房用纸10块
Tasha: Kitchen paper, 10 bucks.
Shure: 10块
Shure: 10 bucks.
Tasha:夹板20
Tasha: Plywood, 20.
Shure: 20
Shure: 20.
Tasha:蛋奶油55
Tasha: Whipping cream 55
Shure: 55
Tasha:低筋面粉7
Tasha: Low-gluten flour 7
Shure: 7
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's 568
Shure: 568的麦当劳
Shure: McDonald's for 568
Katrina: 麦当劳也是你点的
Katrina: You ordered McDonald's too
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Delivery fee 12.6
Tasha:跑腿15
Tasha: Delivery fee 15
Tasha:昨天的披萨点餐169今天中午的饭
Tasha: Yesterday's pizza order 169, today's lunch
Tasha:说吧
Tasha: Go ahead
Shure: 2,366块6
Shure: 2,366.6
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Shure: 没没算错吧应该
Shure: I hope I didn't miscalculate
Tasha:不知道你啊
Tasha: I don't know, you know
Tasha:你不要坑我
Tasha: Don't mess with me
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:你你你坑的不一定是你吧
Jake: Maybe it's not you who's getting tricked
Shure: 哈哈哈我再再来一次
Shure: Hahaha let me do it again
Shure: 再来一次
Shure: One more time
Shure: 我怕
Shure: I'm scared
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven 30
Shure: 30
Tasha:跑腿24
Tasha: Delivery fee 24
Shure: 24
Tasha:装饰房间493
Tasha: Room decoration 493
Shure: 493
Katrina: 咱不需要给他贴那个订单截图吗
Katrina: Don't we need to attach the order screenshots for him?
Tasha:地毯25
Tasha: Carpet 25
Shure: 25
Tasha:达美乐220 跑腿16
Tasha: Domino's 220, delivery fee 16
Tasha:盒马702 厨房用纸10块 夹板20
Tasha: Hema 702, kitchen paper 10, clip board 20
Tasha:淡奶油55
Tasha: Whipping cream 55
Tasha:低筋面粉 7
Tasha: Low-gluten flour 7
Lucia:对我在想我装修的那个
Lucia: Yeah, I'm thinking about my renovation
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's 568
Katrina: 累了
Katrina: I'm tired
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Delivery fee 12.6
Tasha:昨天的跑腿15
Tasha: Yesterday's delivery was 15.
Katrina: 反正500肯定拉满了我
Katrina: Anyway, I'm sure I maxed out at 500.
Tasha:今天中午点餐169
Tasha: Today's lunch order was 169.
Shure: 没错
Shure: That's right.
Lucia:我之前算了
Lucia: I calculated it before.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK.
Lucia:我好像没到
Lucia: I think I didn't reach it.
Shure: 两遍都是2366
Shure: Both times it was 2366.
Lucia:不过过快了
Lucia: But it was too fast.
Jake:两遍都是啊
Jake: Both times, huh?
Jake:行多少
Jake: Okay, how much?
Shure: 3 2366.6
Shure: 3, 2366.6.
Jake:来来来扫扫扫
Jake: Come on, scan it, scan it.
Tasha:你也扫啊
Tasha: You scan it too.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:谢谢你杨老板
Tasha: Thanks, Jake.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go have a feast.
Tasha:还写什么论文呀
Tasha: Forget about the thesis.
Jake:写什么论文吃大餐
Jake: What thesis, let's eat.
Jake:大餐去了
Jake: Big meal, here we come.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go have a feast.
Katrina: 哈哈带人家吃点好的
Katrina: Haha, treat everyone to something nice.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:哎多多少
Jake: Hey, how much?
Jake:2,000
Jake: 2,000.
Shure: 366块6
Shure: 366.6.
Jake:366 好
Jake: 366, okay.
Jake:2300
Jake: 2300.
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha:呃还少带了一个6
Tasha: Uh, you missed a 6.
Tasha:好开始
Tasha: Alright, let's start.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
老板:我靠
Boss: Oh my God.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Tasha:杨老板到底转了多少
Tasha: Jake, how much did you transfer exactly?
Tasha:可恶啊哈哈
Tasha: Damn, haha.
Tasha:他怎么把0加点加上了
Tasha: How did he add the decimal point?
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:不应该加上吗
Jake: Shouldn't it be added?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:我还缺啥吗
Jake: Am I missing anything?
Tasha:其实我觉得可以加
Tasha: Actually, I think we can add...
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:加什么
Jake: Add what?
Tasha:加上那个点
Tasha: Add that point.
Jake:再加6分钱是吧
Jake: Add another 6 cents, right?
Shure: 对我的充电宝
Shure: Right, my power bank.
Katrina: 充电宝还分人吗
Katrina: Do power banks belong to individuals?
Katrina: 我们不都随便拿
Katrina: Don't we just grab any?
Shure: 不是我有一个自带的充电宝
Shure: No, I have my own power bank.
Katrina: 哦哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:你还损失了一个充电宝
Jake: You lost a power bank too?
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha:算上你这笔钱
Tasha: Consider that in your calculation.
Tasha:我这个什么微信收款
Tasha: My WeChat collection...
Tasha:累积到1万块钱了
Tasha: ...has accumulated to 10,000 yuan.
Jake:哦这么真
Jake: Oh, really?
Shure: 然后还有还有什么吗
Shure: So, what else is there?
Tasha:好我的报销完毕
Tasha: Okay, my reimbursement is done.
Shure: 这几天的工资没有谈
Shure: We haven't discussed these days' wages.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, got it.
Jake:你你找找你的充电宝
Jake: You, you look for your power bank.
Jake:你你找找
Jake: You, you look for it.
Jake:对总共就两层
Jake: Yeah, it's only two floors in total.
Shure: 啊这个是我的啊
Shure: Ah, this is mine.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Jake:给他换给他换一个
Jake: Give him a replacement.
Katrina: 算上今天
Katrina: Including today...
Jake:对欠4天
Jake: Yeah, 4 days owed.
Jake:欠4天工资
Jake: 4 days' wages owed.
Jake:然后你你红包抢过吗
Jake: Then, have you ever grabbed a red envelope?
Tasha:欠4天工资
Tasha: 4 days' wages owed.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我一天没领
Tasha: Then I didn't get one for a day.
Jake:你不你第一天抢的红包啊
Jake: Didn't you grab a red envelope on the first day?
Shure: 啊昨天我看一下
Shure: Ah, let me check yesterday.
Tasha:是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:到底是从哪天开始算
Tasha: From which day are we counting?
Tasha:我也不记得算了
Tasha: I don't remember anymore. Forget it.
Katrina: 但是我领过一个这种
Katrina: But I did get one of these.
Katrina: 70的这种
Katrina: One of these 70s.
Katrina: 哦我这还有昨天超市的账我去
Katrina: Oh, I still have the supermarket bill from yesterday.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this one.
Jake:来来来我给你给你算算
Jake: Come on, let me calculate it for you.
Lucia:这瓜还挺好吃啊
Lucia: This melon is pretty tasty.
Tasha:我也觉的
Tasha: I think so too.
Lucia:非常的
Lucia: Really...
Katrina: 我抢了161
Katrina: I grabbed 161.
Katrina: 我靠我抢了3
Katrina: Oh my, I grabbed 3.
Jake:应该是从
Jake: It should be from...
Tasha:你看你
Tasha: Look at you.
Tasha:哎每天整那么花里胡哨自己都忘
Tasha: Every day you make such a fuss that you forget yourself.
Jake:没没忘没有
Jake: No, I didn't forget.
Jake:差点就忘了
Jake: Almost forgot.
Jake:就这个300
Jake: This one, 300.
Jake:第第一天300是吧
Jake: The first day was 300, right?
Jake:嗯然后第二天157 这算吗
Jake: And then the second day 157. Does that count?
Jake:什么嗯
Jake: What, uh-huh.
Jake:就是你你157
Jake: So you, you got 157.
Jake:哎你143领掉了别的应该没有什么
Jake: And then you took 143. There shouldn't be anything else.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Jake:哎还有这个153领掉了是吧
Jake: Oh, and then you took 153, right?
Jake:嗯好嘞
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake:604 好来扫你
Jake: 604. Alright, let's scan you.
Shure: 感谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha:904这是什么
Tasha: 904, what's that?
Shure: 提供打车
Shure: Providing a taxi.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:这是
Jake: This is...
Katrina: 祝大哥顺顺顺什么
Katrina: Wishing you good luck, what?
Jake:三 四天 四天的工资
Jake: Three, four days. Four days' wages.
Katrina: 顺水
Katrina: Smooth sailing.
Tasha:钱 怎么还有4块呢
Tasha: Money. Why is there still 4 bucks?
Jake:因为他之前摸了个红包
Jake: Because he grabbed a red envelope before.
Shure: 顺山顺水顺财神
Shure: Smooth mountains, smooth waters, smooth wealth.
Katrina: 顺顺顺顺顺财神
Katrina: Smooth, smooth, smooth, smooth wealth.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:啥东西啊
Jake: What's that?
Shure: 哦我有钱有钱了
Shure: Oh, I have money now.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: You have money now?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 现在有好多钱
Shure: Now I have a lot of money.
Jake:可以
Jake: That's good.
Shure: 再见了杨老板
Shure: Goodbye, Jake.
Shure: 我会想念你的
Shure: I'll miss you.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure的女友:没关系这全是我的
Shure's GF: It's okay, it's all mine.
Katrina: 你们俩咋回去
Katrina: How are you two getting back?
Katrina: 打车还是什么
Katrina: By taxi or what?
Shure: 打车 还是有点远打车回去
Shure: By taxi. It's a bit far, so by taxi.
Katrina: 打车回去多少钱
Katrina: How much for the taxi?
Shure的女友:不知道好像
Shure's GF: I don't know, maybe...
Katrina: 报哈哈哈
Katrina: Report it, hahaha.
Shure: 社个报吗杨老板
Shure: Report it, Jake?
Jake:这个也能报
Jake: You can report that too.
Shure: 哎呀操打车
Shure: Oh man, taxi.
Jake:你先打你先打你先打
Jake: You go first, you go first, you go first.
Shure: OK哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: OK, oh my god.
Jake:打完
Jake: Done?
Katrina: 哇回武汉能报吗
Katrina: Wow, can we report going back to Wuhan?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:打车回武汉是吗
Jake: Taxi to Wuhan?
Lucia:哦那我打车回家
Lucia: Oh, then I'll take a taxi home.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 打车
Katrina: Taxi.
Tasha:那我打车回个家
Tasha: Then I'll take a taxi home.
Jake:回哪杭州啊
Jake: Where to, Hangzhou?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:要打车回三亚
Lucia: Gotta take a taxi to Sanya.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Alright.
Shure: 我我们把杨老板给榨干了
Shure: We drained Jake dry.
Jake:哈对又惦记又没钱了
Jake: Haha, yeah, now I'm broke again.
Alice:什么打车回三亚
Alice: What, taxi to Sanya?
Lucia:嗯 对
Lucia: Yep, that's right.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Alice:打车回三亚
Alice: Taking a cab back to Sanya
Lucia:我 没有没有开玩笑
Lucia: I'm not, no, I'm not joking
Tasha:他说打车报销
Tasha: He said the cab fare will be reimbursed
Alice:什么时候搭车
Alice: When are we taking the cab?
Tasha:现在啊
Tasha: Now
Jake:明 啊 现在
Jake: Yeah, now
Alice:谁走啊
Alice: Who's leaving?
Jake:他走
Jake: He's leaving
Alice:我也得走
Alice: I need to go too
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake
Lucia:修硕
Lucia: Shure
Shure: 我还第一天长安街的半天的工资
Shure: I still have half a day's wage from the first day on Chang'an Street
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh
Shure: 那个算吗
Shure: Does that count?
Jake:第一天
Jake: The first day
Shure: 去长安街录像的那个
Shure: The day we went to record on Chang'an Street
Jake:哎那应该
Jake: Oh, that should be
Shure: XBZ没给我
Shure: XBZ didn't give it to me
Katrina: 私吞了
Katrina: He pocketed it
Alice:什么叫把谢老板
Alice: What do you mean by "thank the boss"?
Shure: 给谢彬竹发了
Shure: Sent it to Xie Binzhu
Alice:什么榨干
Alice: What do you mean by "squeezed out"?
Katrina: 杨杨老板
Katrina: Jake
Katrina: 老板名字说怎么工资就别想要了
Katrina: If you say the boss's name, you won't get your salary
Lucia:就是蟹老板
Lucia: Exactly, Mr. Crab
Tasha:谢老板
Tasha: Mr. Xie
Lucia:蟹老板
Lucia: Mr. Crab
Jake:蟹老板我们做汉堡
Jake: Mr. Crab, we make burgers
Tasha:卖汉堡的
Tasha: Selling burgers
Jake:哈哈哈 我们一起做汉堡去
Jake: Hahaha, let's make burgers together
Shure: 130
Shure的女友:你打车了吗
Shure's GF: Did you take a cab?
Shure: 138块5毛4
Shure: 138 yuan and 54 cents
Alice:你们带伞了吗
Alice: Did you guys bring umbrellas?
Alice:只有这没下雨
Alice: It's only not raining here
Alice:朝阳都下了
Alice: It's raining in Chaoyang
Alice:要不拿出来
Alice: Should we get them out?
Katrina: 你今天晚上也要走啊
Katrina: You're leaving tonight too?
Jake:等一下啊
Jake: Wait a second
Alice:啊对
Alice: Ah, right.
Jake:看一下
Jake: Let's take a look.
Katrina: 学校有事吗
Katrina: Is there something going on at school?
Alice:对明天有事
Alice: Yeah, there's something tomorrow.
Alice:明天不想早起直接在寝室睡
Alice: I don't want to get up early tomorrow, so I'll just sleep in the dorm.
Katrina: 真好
Katrina: That's nice.
Jake:第0天是150
Jake: Day 0 is 150.
Jake:你你说的是哪一个
Jake: Which one are you talking about?
Shure: 还负一天
Shure: There's even a negative day.
Shure: 你记不记得我提前拿到那个去长安街
Shure: Do you remember I got that thing early to go to Chang'an Street?
Shure: 跟那
Shure: With that...
Alice:所以现在在
Alice: So now it's...
Jake:那算150里啊
Jake: That counts as 150, right?
Shure: 那算这个
Shure: That counts.
Jake:对对对算150
Jake: Yes, yes, it counts as 150.
Katrina: 对对对算钱呢
Katrina: Yes, yes, it counts as money.
Tasha:算工钱
Tasha: It counts as wages.
Katrina: 他问老板包工头要要清钱在这
Katrina: He asked the boss, the contractor, to clear the money here.
Shure: 那就报销一个打车费啦好吧
Shure: Then let's reimburse a taxi fare, okay?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, sure.
Alice:哎我没戴眼镜
Alice: Oh, I didn't bring my glasses.
Shure: 谢谢老板谢谢老板
Shure: Thank you, boss, thank you, boss.
Jake:别打专车就行
Jake: Just don't take a premium cab.
Shure: 没有没有没打专车没打专车
Shure: No, no, I didn't take a premium cab.
Shure: 快车都没敢打
Shure: I didn't even dare to take a fast cab.
Shure: 咱打的是
Shure: We took a...
Tasha:拼车啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: A carpool, hahaha.
Alice:呆会我打车能报销吗我比较近
Alice: Can I get reimbursed if I take a cab later? I'm pretty close.
Jake:都都可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake:可以没问题
Jake: No problem.
Alice:但我没戴眼镜我现在就要把它卸了
Alice: But I don't have my glasses, I'll have to take them off now.
Shure: 但是这个打车费有点贵
Shure: But this cab fare is a bit expensive.
Jake:什么你可以戴眼镜
Jake: What? You can wear glasses.
Shure: 能报眼镜呢
Shure: Can we get glasses reimbursed?
Katrina: 多少钱多少钱多少钱
Katrina: How much, how much, how much?
Tasha:138块5毛4
Tasha: 138 yuan and 54 cents.
Katrina: 小声我以为两开头呢小声
Katrina: Quiet, I thought it was over 200. Quiet.
Jake:100也也行吧
Jake: 100 should be okay, right?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:好说
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 谢谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:杨老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Where are Jake's glasses?
Shure: 今年啊顶会
Shure: This year at the top conference.
Shure: 我感觉靖康的名字要要JKR
Shure: I feel like Jingkang's name should be JKR.
Shure: 这个名字要出现10-10 20次
Shure: This name is going to appear 10-20 times.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Alice:老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Boss, where are your glasses?
Tasha:无语哈哈哈无语
Tasha: Speechless, hahaha, speechless.
Lucia:我也不太了解
Lucia: I don't really know either.
Katrina: 算多
Katrina: Quite a lot.
Katrina: 直接驳倒了
Katrina: Completely refuted.
Katrina: 我驳倒都没发生这么多
Katrina: I refuted it without it happening so much.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 院长了
Shure: Dean.
Shure: 哈哈哈杨院长
Shure: Hahaha, Dean Jake.
Tasha:受不了
Tasha: Can't handle it.
Shure: 哎呦这个名字听着爽爽
Shure: Oh, this name sounds refreshing.
Tasha:受不了啦
Tasha: Can't handle it anymore.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Alice:所以眼镜在哪啊
Alice: So where are the glasses?
Jake:你眼镜
Jake: Your glasses.
Katrina: 那我也来算账
Katrina: Then I'll do the accounting too.
Katrina: 我去拿我的笔点点
Katrina: I'll go get my pen and jot it down.
Alice:这个不是我的
Alice: This isn't mine.
Katrina: 点晚饭了吗
Katrina: Ordered dinner yet?
Jake:你眼镜在
Jake: Your glasses are...
Lucia:没呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Katrina: 感觉我还是没啥胃口
Katrina: I still don't have much of an appetite.
Alice:打完了吗
Alice: Are you done?
Katrina: 吃点西瓜
Katrina: Eat some watermelon.
Alice:我现在要开始拆喽
Alice: I'm going to start unpacking now.
Katrina: 谢彬竹等一会来
Katrina: Xie Binzhu will come in a bit.
Katrina: 谢彬竹说他要住住你的房间
Katrina: Xie Binzhu said he wants to stay in your room.
Tasha:XBZ让他吃完晚饭再来我们
Tasha: XBZ should come after he finishes dinner.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:XBZ晚上还来吗
Alice: Is XBZ coming tonight?
Tasha:他说他发烧了来换个床
Tasha: He said he has a fever and wants to switch beds.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我说修硕走谁跟我玩
Katrina: Hahaha, I said, Shure, who will play with me if you leave?
Katrina: 他说他陪他过来唠嗑
Katrina: He said he would accompany him and chat.
Alice:不是明天中午就结束吗
Alice: Isn't it supposed to end tomorrow at noon?
Tasha:他说他过来唠
Tasha: He said he's coming over to chat.
Tasha:他说他过来唠嗑
Tasha: He said he's coming over for a chat.
Lucia:他来唠嗑
Lucia: He's coming to chat.
Katrina: 嗯他他们应该要帮忙拆东西
Katrina: Yeah, they should be helping to dismantle things.
Katrina: 董叉叉也问我们什么时候退房来着
Katrina: Jack also asked when we would check out.
Alice:哦是拆这些
Alice: Oh, to dismantle these things?
Katrina: 唠嗑指顺便
Katrina: Chatting means doing it along the way.
Jake:不是谢彬竹
Jake: Isn't it Xie Binzhu?
Jake:谢彬竹他到底发不发烧啊
Jake: Is Xie Binzhu having a fever or not?
Shure: 他发着 他确实是发着 发着
Shure: He is. He definitely has a fever.
Jake:他发着就特适合聊天
Jake: If he has a fever, it's perfect for chatting.
Tasha:他啊
Tasha: He is.
Tasha:他太想聊天了
Tasha: He really wants to chat.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina: 他一直想套我的八卦你知道吗
Katrina: He's always trying to get gossip from me, you know?
Katrina: 昨天晚上没问完就走了
Katrina: He left last night without finishing his questions.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 30 37度7还在外面坚持
Shure: With a 37.7-degree fever, he's still hanging in there outside.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:这冷风中是吧 哈哈哈
Jake: In this cold wind, right? Hahaha.
Shure: 他今天应该比昨天还热
Shure: He should be even hotter today than yesterday.
Alice:还是充电宝
Alice: Still a power bank.
Shure: 我觉得保持点距离
Shure: I think we should keep some distance.
Katrina: 对我也感觉
Katrina: Yeah, I feel that too.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 如果我也头疼怎么办
Katrina: What if I get a headache too?
Jake:那那不用保持距离
Jake: Then no need to keep distance.
Jake:那我们跟你保持距离
Jake: We'll keep our distance from you.
Jake:跟你们俩保持距离
Jake: We'll keep our distance from both of you.
Katrina: 我昨天真的是
Katrina: I really was...
Katrina: 要么就是不能加那个青提还是怎么的
Katrina: Either I couldn't add that grape or what.
Alice:怎么没充电宝
Alice: How come there's no power bank?
Jake:充电宝可能有吧
Jake: There should be a power bank, right?
Lucia:让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake:充电宝 拔吧拔吧
Jake: The power bank, pull it out.
Jake:咱也
Jake: Let's...
Katrina: 那我直接算钱算了
Katrina: Then I'll just calculate the money directly.
Katrina: 就不给他发订单截图
Katrina: I won't send him the order screenshot.
Shure: 杨老板太大气
Shure: Jake, you're so generous.
Shure: 后来 杨老板像 多多财运
Shure: Later, Jake seemed to have a lot of good fortune.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:他
Tasha: He...
Shure: 他老板说他请的助手还混了
Shure: His boss said the assistant he hired was still messing around.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 但杨老板你看我给你省了500块钱房屋装修费
Shure: But Jake, look, I saved you 500 bucks on renovation costs.
Jake:哎那确实那确实
Jake: Yeah, that's true, that's true.
Tasha:怎么省呢
Tasha: How did you save it?
Lucia:他没装修啊
Lucia: He didn't do any renovations.
Jake:省成这样省成这样
Jake: Saved it like this, saved it like this.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 那咱是不是省了吗
Shure: Didn't we save it?
Jake:省啊省啊
Jake: Saved, saved.
Shure: 就是因为我本来
Shure: It's because I originally...
Tasha:你就说花的值不值吗值
Tasha: Just say, was it worth spending the money? Yes.
Jake:值  哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, hahaha.
Shure: 就是数据集这要保证多样性
Shure: It's like, this dataset needs to ensure diversity.
Shure: 就是有人需要装修有人不需要
Shure: Some people need renovations, some don't.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 你下次给我住毛坯房就行
Shure: Next time, just give me an unfinished house.
Shure: 只要工资到位
Shure: As long as the salary is in place.
Tasha:给给
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Shure: 倒挂着住也没关系
Shure: I don't mind living upside down.
Tasha:住那个
Tasha: Living like that...
Jake:那行下次就这么定了
Jake: Alright, it's settled for next time then.
Tasha:那个8块钱一天的那个
Tasha: The one that costs 8 bucks a day.
Jake:啊富塞倒碑塔
Jake: Ah, the one at the Fusai Daobei Tower.
Lucia:你这个研究逐渐变态在下去要塞道去了
Lucia: Your research is getting so weird, it's going off the rails.
Shure: 阴塞道那是什么鬼
Shure: What's that weird thing?
Shure: 我要倒立
Shure: I need to do a handstand.
Shure: 怎么着也得500一天吧
Shure: It should at least be 500 a day, right?
Tasha:我靠那还是让他住房吧
Tasha: Damn, just let him live in a house.
Shure: 我比房子都贵
Shure: I'm more expensive than the house.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  董叉叉问我什么时候离开
Katrina: Jack asked me when I'm leaving.
Jake: 问你什么时候离开
Jake: Asked when you're leaving?
Katrina:  他说靖康应该要在你们后收拾东西
Katrina: He said Jingkang should pack up after you guys.
Katrina:  他他是不是要过来帮忙
Katrina: Is he coming to help?
Katrina:  所以他要协调自己的时间是吗
Katrina: So he needs to coordinate his time, right?
Jake: 他可能是吧
Jake: Maybe, yeah.
Jake: 他为什么不问我呢
Jake: Why didn't he ask me?
Tasha:我哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina:  有道理哈
Katrina: Makes sense, haha.
Katrina:  我要帮他看一下
Katrina: I need to help him check.
Katrina:  卧槽这这小狐狸真就没了
Katrina: Oh no, the little fox is really gone.
Lucia: 哎 我靠
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 好我可以先滚蛋了
Shure: Okay, I can leave now.
Jake: 吃个西瓜压压惊
Jake: Let's eat some watermelon to calm down.
Tasha: 谁下呢哈哈哈
Tasha: Who's going next? Haha.
Shure: 怎么抖了呢杨老板你手
Shure: Why are your hands shaking, Jake?
Jake:什么东西呀
Jake: What is this?
Shure: 好惨呢
Shure: So miserable.
Alice:这窗帘真的很像婚纱的质地啊
Alice: This curtain really feels like wedding dress material.
Alice:所以做婚纱为什么不能用窗帘
Alice: So why can't we use curtains to make wedding dresses?
Lucia: 可能说亲肤吧哈哈
Lucia: Maybe it's about skin-friendliness, haha.
Tasha: 可能用的是一块布
Tasha: Maybe it's just one piece of fabric.
Tasha: 但是为了显肤
Tasha: But to make it look good on skin.
Alice: 我以为他走了
Alice: I thought he left.
Lucia: 洗一下
Lucia: Wash it.
Alice:有一股工厂的味
Alice: It smells like a factory.
Lucia: 对 新的这些布料
Lucia: Yes, new fabrics do.
Lucia: 没事 不用洗了
Lucia: It's okay, no need to wash it.
Alice: 让刘婷拿着玩吧
Alice: Let Liu Ting play with it.